this video was made possible by
Squarespace
build your website for 10% off by going
to Squarespace comm slash Wendover the
commercial airline industry is the
classic duopoly in the US there's Boeing
the long successful manufacturer our
most known for its iconic 747 and in
Europe there's Airbus the more recent
entrant formed of a consortium of
various European manufacturers and
that's pretty much it
two-thirds of all airplanes currently
flying commercially are made by one of
these two manufacturers but there's
something that these manufacturers don't
do they don't make small planes but
that's not for lack of trying
Airbus tried when they made their a 318
a variant of their successful a320 but
only sold 80 of them Boeing did as well
with their 707 but it too was a
commercial failure with only a hundred
and fifty six sales but that doesn't
mean that there's no place for small
planes in fact it's a significant market
that the Giants of the aviation industry
have not been able to touch if you step
on a plane to a small airport nowadays
there's a good chance that it's either
made by Embraer or Bombardier Embraer
the Brazilian manufacturer launched
their a jet family just over 15 years
ago and to date have sold nearly 1500 of
them by all accounts it's a fantastic
airplane and there are whole airports
that rely on them nearly 70% of the more
than a hundred daily flights out of the
small London City Airport operate using
an Embraer e-jet due to the noise
restrictions steep approach angle and
short runway this is one of the few
planes that can operate there and some
airlines such as British Airways owned
the e jet exclusively for use at this
Airport the US with this nearly 400
commercial airports and vast size has
serviced to many more smaller airports
than year upper Asia thanks to
government subsidies so hundreds of
airports in the US are served by non
Boeing or Airbus jets there's a serious
place for small planes and bombardier
knows this Bombardier while still one of
Canada's largest companies is a small
player in the commercial airplane market
only making about 6 percent of the
world's commercial planes the company
has long made the successful CRJ
regional jets but ten years ago
bombardier had an idea for something
else they were going to make a
more efficient airplane to fit between
the size of small regional jets and the
larger planes of Boeing and Airbus the
CSeries
this plane was going to take advantage
of all the modern advancements in
aircraft design composite construction
advanced aerodynamics and high bypass
engines to make one of the most
efficient small airplanes on the market
from 2007 onwards the parts were
selected the plane was developed and
sales were booked then on September 16th
it took flight for the first time at
this point the company was adamant that
the aircraft would enter into commercial
service just one year later in 2014 but
then the problems began while doing
routine testing on the ground at the
Mirabelle Airport manufacturing base one
of the test aircraft suffered an
uncontained engine failure not only did
this strike a serious blow to the
aircraft development timeline it also
prevented the manufacturer from
exhibiting their new plane at the
Farnborough airshow
the largest and most important tradeshow
in the industry where the company
expected to secure crucial aircraft
orders the show only happens every two
years so this was a significant setback
some questioned whether the program
could survive this blow and it only
barely did the program was nearly out of
money in 2015
without the significant financial
support of the governments of Canada and
Quebec the program and company likely
would not have survived but it did and
on June 15th 2016 the aircraft entered
service with Swiss Airlines on its first
ever commercial flight from Zurich to
Paris by all accounts the CSeries is a
fantastic airplane for airlines it's
efficient and versatile while passengers
praised its rare level of passenger
comfort for a small plane it even has a
range of up to 3,800 miles meaning it
could hypothetically fly transatlantic
into small airports like London and
Belfast City airports as of October 2017
there are fourteen CSeries planes
currently flying nine for Swiss Airlines
and five for air Baltic but they have
nearly 350 orders enough to make the
programme profitable but until recently
they lacked the most valuable kind of
order American ones with its tendency to
use smaller planes the American market
will make or
break the program and Bombardier knew
this they were desperate for an order
from one of the main three US airlines
to prove its viability so much so that
they allegedly sold 75 of them to Delta
for only 20 million dollars each a
quarter of the 80 million dollar listing
price for Delta but it was low enough
that it might have been illegal this is
a practice known as dumping the cost for
Bombardier to make a C series plane is
about thirty million dollars so was
selling these planes that they hadn't
even made yet at a loss because they
wanted to gain prevalence in the US
market predatory pricing techniques like
this are against the law in the US and
many other countries so Boeing took
action and filed a dumping petition with
the US Department of Commerce but here's
the problem
Boeing doesn't make an equivalent
airplane to the C series they say that
the dumping will curtail the sale of its
smaller 737-700 planes but Delta itself
has said that they didn't want the 737s
Boeing couldn't offer them a delivery
slot before 2020 and the 737 is a
fundamentally different plane the C
series has better range can take off
from a shorter runway is more efficient
and is empirically a smaller airplane
boeing claims that Bombardier received
subsidies that allowed for the below
market pricing but the money Bombardier
received from the governments of Quebec
and Canada came in either exchange for
ownership of the program or in the form
of interest-free loans that will be paid
back
Boeing on the other hand has received
over fourteen billion dollars in
subsidies in the last 20 years through
tax breaks from US state and federal
governments nonetheless Boeing asked the
US Department of Commerce to impose an
80 percent tariff on the plane to bring
the price above the manufacturing cost
the US Department of Commerce responded
by placing a 300 percent tariff on the
plane at this point it seemed like the
end of the line for the Bombardier plane
with a tariff that high it could never
be both competitive and profitable in
the crucial US market but then Airbus
stepped in on October 16 2017 the two
companies announced that Airbus would be
acquiring a 50 point zero one percent
stake in the C
Cirie's program Bombardier is just
giving away this steak for free but the
reason this is so great for them is for
one airbus is a marketing and sales
powerhouse their resources far
outstripped those of Bombardier and they
will be able to sell more planes than
Bombardier could ever have dreamt of on
the other side since the CSeries doesn't
really overlap in size with any Airbus
plane Airbus gains a new modern airplane
in their lineup that will allow Airlines
to have truly all Airbus fleets but the
real reason Bombardier partnered up with
Airbus is because of this Airbus is
final assembly line in Mobile Alabama by
assembling the CSeries
aircraft in the u.s. they'll essentially
be American planes which means that they
won't be subject to US import tariffs at
least according to Bombardier
Boeing believes that they will still be
subject to the tariff since they're
still the same planes that receive
subsidies while some external observers
have suggested that only the 48 percent
of the plane manufactured outside of the
US will be subject to the 300 percent
tariff what will actually happen is up
to the US Department of Commerce
independent analysts have estimated that
over the next 20 years there will be
demand for about 5,500 aircraft of the C
series as sized before the Airbus
takeover bombardier was expected to
fulfill 40% of that demand just over
2000 planes after the takeover the C
series is expected to capture up to 60
percent of that market well over 3,000
planes
that's tens of billions of dollars in
additional revenue and the C series now
has real potential to become an iconic
airplane well it would have been hard to
predict this turn of events this
takeover directly brought on by Boeing's
actions proves a hard hitting blow to
the company without spending a cent on
development Airbus now has a plane in a
market segment that Boeing cannot
compete with the C series will dominate
this market segment and every cent
Airbus and Bombardier makes is money
lost on Boeing's part just as Boeing
expected the C series will hurt its
business in the US but now it'll happen
with a fully legal american-made plane
if you have a business a YouTube channel
a podcast and event or anything else you
need a website and there's nowhere
better to be
than Squarespace I made all my websites
with Squarespace because their website
builder and customizable templates make
it easy to set up a great looking
website they also handle all the setup
hosting and maintenance of the website
so you really don't have to worry about
anything if you ever have any issue they
have 24/7 award-winning customer support
to help you out what's great is that
they're offering Wendover productions
viewers 10% off their already reasonable
prices exclusively by going to
squarespace.com slash Wendover they make
this show possible and are truly a great
company so please do at least go check
them out over at squarespace.com slash
Wendover thanks for watching and I'll
see you again in two weeks for another
Wendover productions video
[Music]